thank you to president tourists and
directors of the Harvard Alumni
Association thank you very much for that
generous introduction I hope to become
the man you described to president Faust
Fellows of Harvard College and members
of the Board of Overseers juh Provost
Garber and members of the faculty and
staff to the members of the Reunion
classes and all of the distinguished
guests proud families and friends and
most especially deserving graduates of
the class of 2015 I am deeply honored to
be with you today humbled in fact to be
in the company of my fellow honor ants
both those honored today and throughout
the university storied history and I'm
awed to be in the presence of all the
brainpower and promise gathered here
this afternoon but I am also a little
intimidated 41 years ago when I was a
freshman in hall-worthy over there
surrounded I know I know
surrounded by my brilliant new
classmates I was convinced there would
come a soft knock at the door one night
from the Dean of Admissions with the
awkward news that my admission had been
a mistake and that I should quietly
gather my things I often feel that way
here in Cambridge not just at this
August institution I've spent the past
semester as a visiting fellow at the
innovation Institute at MIT now while
some of my vintage may still refer to
MIT derisive ly as that vocational
school just downriver
I met students there who were already
dazzling Nobel laureates with their
inventions as teenagers even campaigning
for governor was a special challenge in
Cambridge I can't even count the number
of times out on the trail when I was
asked a policy question by someone who
had already written a book
on the subject I traced these feelings
in part to the fact that as a kid
Harvard was not part of my universe I
grew up as Cynthia said on welfare on
the south side of Chicago and was the
first in my family to go to college when
I told my grandmother I'd been admitted
to Harvard she screamed with pride and
delight and then she paused and asked
now where is that anyway
that same grandmother would be proud
today she would react to the feelings
I've described having when I'm in this
rarefied community by smiling and saying
it keeps you humble of course a
cantabrigian would more likely sniff and
paraphrase Winston Churchill and quip
that I have much to be humble about all
of which is to say to you graduates in
particular today that I know how gifted
you are how well-prepared you are how
high achieving and sought-after you are
I know how confident you are in your
talents and your opinions and I know the
world needs much of what you have to
offer the world is indeed yours for the
taking even so I want to urge you to be
a little uneasy I'm not talking about
the kind of unease all new graduates
feel about careers or money or romance
I'm not inviting you to feel envious of
your classmates accomplishments or
unworthy of your own I'm talking about
the kind of unease that comes from being
a little unsure that you already know
all you need to know the kind of
restlessness that compels you to look
beyond yourself for answers and meaning
you graduates came to Harvard with big
ideas and you leave with big capacities
but still as my grandmother would say
what you don't know could fill a book as
far as you have journey to achieve
today's milestone your education is in
fact incomplete think of yourselves
instead as educated more in the sense
that Louis Pasteur
described as learning to listen to
anything without losing your confidence
or your temper because if you are
listening listening with unease you will
hear the yearnings of a restless world
I'm not sure we were listening very
closely to those journeys when I was an
undergraduate in the mid-1970s Harvard
had just settled down from a long season
of student unrest a few years before
student protests over the Vietnam War
had rocked this campus and women moving
into the formerly all-male River houses
had been a source of widespread upset
only a few years before that
grandmothers and school kids preachers
and sharecroppers had marched over the
Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma to demand
access to the ballot in other words on
the eve of my arrival on this campus
civil and human rights and indeed issues
of war and peace were matters of current
events by the time I got to campus
students were comparatively complacent
because we had missed all the fun we
occasionally acted out in offbeat ways
in Dunster house we got all excited
exercise over the decision to stop
serving hot breakfast in the dining hall
cold cereal fruit yogurt pastries juice
coffee all this would be available every
morning but if we wanted an egg we'd
have to walk a block to Leverett house
outrageous so one spring morning we
marched on lever II complete with
banners beating drums and scores of
fellow students never before seen at
breakfast time we took to the streets
over pancakes so it's a marvelous
improvement in my view to see students
these days take to the streets over
issues of real consequence in response
to the yawning economic gap between the
rich and the poor in this country
workers and
students and many others set up tent
caps tent camps on Wall Street and the
Occupy movement quickly spread to many
other cities including Boston the
killings of unarmed black men by
unaccountable police officers in
Ferguson Missouri and Staten Island New
York moved young people and many others
to take to the streets to proclaim black
lives matter the failure of national
policymakers and citizens alike to
reverse climate change compels students
faculty and alumni on this campus and
others to ignite a new divestment
movement predictably predictably each of
these actions has been criticized the
Occupy movement is faulted for having no
agenda beyond discontent for having
called attention to the critical truth
that social mobility a central feature
of the American idea is disappearing
without offering a solution the marchers
under the banner of black lives matter
matter are faulted for similar
shortcomings for trying to shut down
highway traffic instead of proposing
specific programs and policies to help
us heal the devastating lack of
Understanding between police and young
black men climate change activists are
faulted for putting symbols above
substance by demanding divestment and
fossil fuel companies when this is
widely believed to be unlikely to affect
anybody's actual behavior I share some
of those concerns but I am also grateful
that students today are putting far more
important issues on the table than hot
breakfast
indeed I welcome the engagement of
today's generation of activists and the
heightened consciousness they have
demanded of the rest of us and I am
hopeful that those in power will make
more of the profound ends they seek than
of the imperfect means of their protest
don't get me wrong I hate my behavior
I hate violence of any kind I don't want
unrest in the streets but I do want
unrest in our hearts and minds I do want
us all to be uneasy about the grim
realities of black men and families and
the widespread nonchalance about poverty
I want us to be uneasy about the chronic
desperation of communities some of us
are just one generation away from living
in about the way we de humanized the
fellow souls we call alien about the
carelessness with which we treat the
planet itself I want us to ask ourselves
hard questions and to ask our leaders
hard questions about the state of the
American dream why the poor are stuck in
poverty and why the middle class are
just one paycheck away from being poor
and I want us all to be a little
uncomfortable about a feel about how few
of our comforts we share I want us to be
uneasy because if enough of us are
uneasy we might begin to feel some
urgency about finding the solutions to
the things that make us so I honor the
work that many philanthropies and
government programs and in debate
individual saints do to show compassion
and kindness to others as governor I saw
up close the practical impact that
affordable housing or sentencing reform
or a great teacher has on an individual
on a family or on a neighborhood and if
policy most matters most where it
touches people
maybe it's the point of individual
contact that we should celebrate most
but somehow to settle for only that is
to make peace with large-scale suffering
to accept the way things are as the way
they ought to be and to me that seems
fundamentally on American this is the
only nation in human history organized
around a set of Civic
aspirations not religion or language or
geography or even a common culture none
of the things that normally organized a
nation but instead a handful of
transcendent civic ideals and we have
defined those values over time and
through struggle as freedom equality
opportunity and fair play these are the
ties that bind us across time and all
sorts of mostly superficial differences
and that have made America the envy of
the world as one great Israeli statesman
puts it America is the only superpower
whose power comes from giving not from
taking indeed our greatest gift to this
poor black kid from Chicago and to
strivers of every type and kind for
generations is a reason to hope in fits
and starts through our history those
values have compelled us to reach higher
to do big things and I worry that as a
nation we are forgetting how over 16
million of our neighbors and family
members who once couldn't can now afford
to see a doctor thanks to the
president's health care reforms and yet
and yet we focus on the embarrassing
fact that at the outset the website
didn't work as if that discredits the
objective itself our roads rails and
bridges are in a state of dangerous
disrepair needing years of focused work
and the best our Congress can muster is
funding for two months before they leave
on vacation when president Faust called
to invite me to Andres address you this
morning or afternoon she reminded me
that from this very podium General
George C Marshall announced the Marshall
Plan to rebuild Europe after World War
two I wonder what reaction general
Marshalls idea would elicit today a
collective groan a wistful sigh and yet
across America and across the globe big
ideas are exactly what the world craves
the graduates of this university are
trained to think big will you be uneasy
enough to act big what will you do with
what you know you know that the answer
to chronic poverty is opportunity that
opportunity comes from an economy that
grows out to the marginalized not just
up to the well-connected
and you know that economic growth of
this kind requires a massive
reinvestment of ideas and money by
industry and by government in schools in
infrastructure and in the innovation
industries that are fueling the future
you know that community policing where
police are of and in the communities
they serve is a strategy that makes us
safer and you also know that whatever
methods we pursue for better policing
race and racism is still too close to
the surface of everything from commerce
to the Twitter commentary about whom
celebrities date you know that what's
happening in Ferguson or Baltimore is
but the frayed edge of a neglect that is
undermining our country and that
declaring ourselves officially race
blind or post-racial as a way to end
division and discord is neither honest
nor responsible you know
you know that climate change is too
serious a threat to human survival to
tolerate anything less than an orderly
and purposeful shift to a carbon limited
if not carbon free economy and you also
know you also know that that requires a
plan with all players yes including big
oil and coal at the table and that the
way to move us all together is to seize
the countless opportunities to create
wealth and jobs which such a transition
has and will present poverty racism
climate change big even daunting
challenges but every one is of our own
making and surely therefore cannot be
beyond our capacity to care about and to
solve we have leaders here in this
graduating class ready to chart a course
to that higher ground ready to listen
for the needs and the answers that are
rising from community and to drive the
innovations and make the sacrifices
necessary to save our country and our
kind we need you and we need you to be
uneasy
we need uneasy leaders who can get
outside your own ambitions and think
about the worlds we need uneasy leaders
who won't let your ideals be casualties
of your confrontations with reality who
refused as dr. King said to accept
despair as the final response to the
ambiguities of history we need uneasy
leaders straining to hear the yearnings
of the powerless as clearly as we do the
expectations of the powerful and willing
to think and to act big I'm especially
proud of the performance of
Massachusetts students during my tenure
as governor
I'm proud of the fact that not only did
we fund the schools at record highs in
each of the years I served even during
the global economic collapse but our
students ranked first in the nation in
student achievement each year and at or
near the top in the world in math and
science and yet for nearly two decades
that we've been on our education reform
journey here in Massachusetts
achievement gaps persisted and the kids
stuck in those gaps are poor or kids
with special needs or kids who speak
English as a second language of course
to have an achievement gap at all it's
an educational and an economic challenge
but to let it language languish for as
long as we had was to my mind a moral
question because those are our children
too and that made us uneasy so we set to
work on a big reform and we faced all
the predictable hurdles and naysayers
the Charter advocates had one certain
answer the teachers union had another
the business community had yet another
parents and suburbs had one set of
demands not always consistent with
parents and cities and so on and so on
in the end we put the children first we
acknowledge that all children can learn
and that all have their own ways of
doing so and ultimately we crafted a
piece of legislation that provided new
rules and tools to meet children where
they are it was a triumph of every
interest group for the common interest
and slowly but demonstrably we are
closing achievement gaps in
Massachusetts what was the big idea that
no child's destiny should be defined by
her zip code of birth I visited a school
in Boston that was using all of these
new tools on every man
in just a few years that school had
lifted itself from one of the worst in
the city to one of the best in the state
his students were proud of their
achievements and purposeful about their
future you could see it not just in
their test scores but in their eyes
their posture their attitudes they have
not yet overcome their poverty they have
steep hills yet to climb but they will
climb them because now they have a
reason to hope and they are making the
very best of it they and children like
them everywhere are the reason the
idealism of you graduates matters I'm
not asking you to live in a world of
ideals alone idealism is no substitute
for hard-nosed problem-solving to make
change you have to gain influence and
use power to develop policy and
implement action plans to be accountable
you have to organize but ideals let us
imagine big ideas and you can't organize
what you can't imagine so I welcome you
graduates to a world of big needs in
search of big thinking and big actions I
welcome you to a world where a few will
find countless reasons why you can't
while countless masses silently pray you
will I welcome you to a world where
great beauty and extravagant kindness
lives side by side with unspeakable
cruelty suffering and neglect and I
challenge you to be so uneasy about that
that you are compelled to ask who but
you should act good luck and God bless
you class of 2015 thank you very much
you